hey everybody its Jessie and welcome to
live coding with Jessie and we have a
lot to do today I want to get this app
submitted to the App Store today and I'd
love to do it while I'm on the stream so
I think so if y'all can hear me put some
in the chat the live stream is analytics
look a little bit weird but let me know
otherwise I'm gonna get started I see
there's a lot of people in the chat
saying hello so hey everybody just a
quick a quick intro we've been working
on this app before this is the fifth
live stream
alright cool it looks like you can hear
me for some reason my video preview in
the like the stream settings panel is
saying the videos private which is
really odd since obviously you all are
in the chat but I've never had it show
that before alright so we've been
working on this app for 5 live streams
now and we are using we're connecting a
react native app that's built with Expo
with a brain-computer interface called
the notion by a startup company called
neuro City and we've successfully
connected it so that it measures we wear
this device it measures our level of
focus and when we drop below a certain
level the screen changes to red and it
makes a device vibrate so just really
kind of like bear essential
functionality and now I want to actually
put it out there so we can test it on
devices so we got a lot to do before we
can put it out there and I've been going
over some of the documentation just so
that I have some idea of this process
this is my
very first time actually publishing so
I've I've made a few apps that that
definitely work and I can run on devices
but I've never actually gone through the
step of putting it out to the App Store
and there's a few extra things you need
to do to get your app from working to
publishable so that's what we're going
to do today I'm gonna set a timer and
here on one of my other screens and when
that timer goes off so it's gonna be 25
minutes and that timer goes off I'm
gonna go over to the live chat I'm gonna
answer some questions so there's a lot
of you in the chat I see you and I'm not
gonna ignore you forever I'm just gonna
focus on doing the work for about 25
minutes and then I'm gonna go to the
chat answer as many questions as I can
so feel free to ask as many questions as
you want in the chat I will get to them
and you know keep it keep it positive
and try to keep the spam down the last
couple of streams it's been a little bit
weird we've had a lot of people spamming
the chat and by that I mean they're just
they keep saying the same things over
and over again they're just typing in a
bunch of nonsense over and over again it
makes it really hard to read the chat
for everybody watching so try to keep
that to a minimum if I see that you're
doing that then I will stop you from
being in the chat so I really I won't
even mention anything like I'm just
gonna stop you from you into the chat so
there's not gonna really be a warning I
don't have time for that especially if
you get a lot of people in the stream
like we have right now so if it gets too
bad I might have a moderator but really
it's it's never been a problem before I
mean we've done like literally hundreds
of streams and it's only been the last
few streams it's been a problem so
obviously any type of like bad language
or you know saying mean things to each
other stuff like that you're gonna be
out of the chat so let's keep it all
positive okay all right so this gets
started if you want to try to follow
along this project is on github
I believe I put a link in the
description to the the code on github so
you can check out the code I'm also
gonna be on the on Expo so their
documentation let me put the link to the
docs that I'm using in the chat so I got
a lot of these windows open for things
that we need to do and so I'm gonna be
jumping around a little bit but this is
where I started at the link I just put
in the chat so this started this is
where I started we're gonna start from
here so we're starting with deploying
the app right so from deploying the app
I believe I went to distributing or
deploying yeah this is the distributing
so we need to create native builds so to
build the app I told you is gonna be a
lot of jumping around here the docs for
Expo are actually really good but it's
there's a lot of steps here so we we've
I believe we do have the expo CLI
installed already which actually I can
let me double check that now make sure I
have it installed I know I have
installed one of my machines I actually
might not have it on this one so we
might need to do that whoops
let's make some space here because we're
gonna be in the in the terminal a bit
more than normal so I want to see all
right it looks like yeah we have this
installed otherwise we wouldn't be
getting all of this stuff so yeah I
believe we have this Expo now it says
for Windows users we need to have WSL
enabled so we need to do that so this
step if you're on a Mac or if you're on
Linux you probably won't need to do this
step if you're on Windows you need to do
this step so let's do this so I have the
documentation open already for this we
do install the windows subsystem for
Linux so I'll make this a bit bigger
I've never done this before let's see
let's see if it works so we need to copy
this and run it in PowerShell as an
admin so let's try to open Windows
PowerShell and let's see if we can run
as administrator yes
all right so we're running PowerShell as
an admin and see if I can make it bigger
alright I don't know how to make it make
the text bigger but I'm just copying and
pasting what I just got out of this
window on the right hand side and enable
Windows optional feature cool all right
so it looks like it's doing something
here let's see do you want to restart
the computer to complete operation now
oh no I gotta restart all right it looks
like we're gonna have to restart so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
restart which basically the stream is
just gonna freeze up for like a second
the restarts on this machine because
it's pretty new or actually very quick
so let's just get it over with now let's
restart I should be back hang in there
for maybe like I don't know two minutes
at the most and
and we'll do this restart
you
all right cool can you all hear me now
in my back it looks like I'm back
I'm gonna keep going all right sweet
back up yeah actually the the thing that
took me the longest that was a really
quick restart was that it restarted me
and by default my YouTube account is set
to my personal account so it tried to
log me back into the free code camp
control panel but it wouldn't let me in
because I wasn't free code camp so I
switched to my phone for a second just
to give you all an update but anyway
it's working now so let me turn the
stream off on my phone and let's bring
to get rid of my VPN and bring up my
code suites actually honestly like if
you get a good Windows system restarts
are really fast
it used to be Windows were like super
hard to restart sweet looks like there's
a vs code extension for the Windows
Linux subsystem so I'm just gonna
install it because it seems like
cool I'll read about more about that
later on but I guess it's good to have
semantic highlighting has been applied
sweets all right
so now that we have that we can continue
on we need to install a Linux
distribution I think I'm gonna go with
Ubuntu because that's what I'm used to
using out of out of any Linux distro I
don't really know if anybody has any
suggestions as to whether to install
ubuntu 16.04 or 18.04 let me know in the
chat I've used 16 more often but I don't
really know what the difference is in
upgrading to 18 so I'm gonna have to
make a decision here in like three
minutes
so just let me know let's go 16 or 18
alright so looks like we got one vote
for 18 I'll go with 18 I mean honestly
it's obviously the the new the newer
version so it may as well go to newer
version I'm open this in a new window so
I can keep the documentation open and
let's read the next it looks like we
open it up we just get it it installs it
and then we initialize which I already
have as that documentation open as well
so we'll do the initialization it looks
like everybody saying 18 cool gam zero
zero two says do Debian it's the most
stable if I had more time to research
maybe I'd think about Debian but for
right now like it's been a while since I
use the boon to but I'm more familiar
with all the commands and stuff so I
think I want you to go to boon to not I
don't really think that we're gonna have
to do that much with it I think it just
needs to be installed to do the rest of
the steps for expo but let's get that
and get it started yeah this open
Microsoft Store
get it installed
all right it's going pretty quick
doesn't seem like it'll be too too much
longer so once we get this we need to
initialize so let's look at these steps
while we're waiting for the install and
just so we'll launch it and I need to
set up an account update an upgrade the
packages hopefully this doesn't take too
long and that's it
all right that's that's pretty easy we
probably could just get that started and
then move on to another step and while
we're waiting for that to finish this is
really sweet uh-hum colors they get look
at this they got the weather on air I
wonder how they had that all set up
anyway that's pretty cool this is kind
of cool I'm actually glad I'm getting
installed I'm installing this I'm gonna
probably play around with this after the
stream ok cool so almost done with the
installation looks like maybe 75% of the
way done there so we'll get to that in a
second I think we can get rid of this
step we can get rid of this step now and
what else can we get rid of yay all
right so let's launch it so installing
this may take a few minutes so not a
problem we got other steps that we can
do that don't depend on this step yet so
there's a guide here to deploying to the
App Store's
and there's a lot of stuff up making
sure it works on different phones I'm
gonna skip over a lot of that because
really this for this first NVP launch
like it just needs to work on my phone
alright that was really fast enter a new
user name I'm just gonna enter
my name and I'm gonna create a password
with LastPass
and let's paste that in there see if it
lets me paste cool what alright so I
guess it's not allowing copy and paste
so I'm just gonna have to type in the
password alright cool
sweet so we're in now we need to do our
apt-get so right copy this we're gonna
do sudo which like lets you run as an
admin and then update and upgrade all
our apps taste that why is it not
letting me paste anything thank you
alright well I'll just type it in sudo
upgrade and yeah oops I messed it up
updates and
all right cool that's doing its thing
well it looks like some EEP says control
shift copy and paste for copy and
pasting and Linux terminal
oh I Michael says to all right sweet
thank you for that oh I will definitely
be using that in the future all right so
we just need to wait for that and one of
the next steps we need to have is an app
icon and a splash screen so I'm gonna go
with the it says we need to provide
something that at least 512 by 512
pixels but we need 1024 by 1024 for iOS
so eventually we're gonna be on iOS so I
think we're just gonna go with 1024 by
1024 I you want to continue yes let's
continue so I have a free image editing
software called [ __ ] so GI MP I'm just
gonna use that let's see I think I
already started a didn't save I started
like right before the stream a template
but we can just create it again so I'm
just gonna create one that's the
dimensions we want 1024 by 1024 so now
we have this we have our background and
let's let's just make a solid color
background I don't know what color to do
was just there we go there's our Paint
Bucket color fill there's a pattern fill
well what patterns can we do
background background color fill fill
hole selection all right what colors
right now we have black and red there
black and white let's change it to
something else
how about just this blue color let's use
blue
I think our buttons blue in our app so
that's like the only color we're using
other than like the red color so let's
do that
why is that not filling there we go all
right so we got our color here let's
make a new layer new layer and let's
call this layer text and inside our text
layer let's add a text box and I'm just
going to type in our text box s F
and the color we're gonna we're gonna
make the color white so we can actually
see it and let's make the text like like
a hundred pixels and let's use there we
go let's use this font I don't know why
I can't see it
oops kiss the colour air got changed
there we go
you can tell I'm not like I'm not at all
very skilled at at this kind of work so
my icon is just gonna be letters and
we're just gonna make big letters on a
background because I I'm not skilled at
anything artistic so eventually it'd be
cool to like get a real icon but for
right now I just need to get something
done actually I mean let me check back
in on this Linux thing cool it looks
like everything ran all right so I think
we're we're good
and we're good with Linux I'm gonna
leave it open just in case there's
another step that I forgot about but I
think we're good and everything's fine
for that step of getting the Linux
distro so let's see that looks like
pretty much in the center I'm not too
worried about it so we can export this
as so we can do is first first thing we
can do is save and let's save this as
just SFX CF so that way we can come in
and edit it if we need to and then we're
gonna export it as a pain so SF dot PNG
okay so we have that exported now let me
check I think my 25 minutes is up the
time I got reset when I restarted so let
me let me go back to the chat right now
for about five minutes I'm gonna go back
to the chat I'm gonna answer some
questions when we come back we're gonna
take this same design here and just
change the dimensions and we're going to
make a splash screen and then we should
have everything we need to go forward
with doing our first like build maybe we
might use the Android simulator in
Android studio to do one test run before
we actually deploy it but we're getting
close to being able to deploy this all
right so let's see the chat there's a
lot of people saying hello so hello
everybody
if someone says stay home stay safe
korone effect
yeah for sure let's see someone's asking
will I learn web development in this I
assume they're asking like in this live
stream where you learn web development
this one probably not because we want a
lot of like setup work there's not
really a lot of code going on in this
stream but in the previous streams we do
a lot more code so you might learn a
little bit more from that see I'm a
full-stack myrn web developer so that's
what [ __ ] Express reacts and nginx
is that man I think that's right I need
or is it not nginx is it node I can't
believe I can't remember what Marin
stikes stands for is the end in myrna
node or nginx let me know in the chat
cuz I can't remember I need a project
please help me actually I worked on up
work but I don't get any job last month
and then there's a Skype so yeah if
anybody needs a Martin stack developer
for a project check out the chat at the
beginning of the stream for
new nuru Suleman has their Skype info in
there yeah actually a lot of people are
getting laid off at least in the United
States a lot of people are getting fired
because of the corona virus so that's
rough like hang in there everybody I
know that's tough my wife lost their job
on on Monday so I definitely understand
and things are rough so if you can help
each other out if you didn't lose your
job like you know try to help you to
help out where you can
someone asked what coding language this
is the app is built with JavaScript so
with react native somebody's spam in the
chat see let's high we're gonna hide
that so let's see
Ahmir asked if there's a playlist of
this you know what now that we have you
know we're up to five streams now I
think I will make a playlist of this so
that'll be coming I'll try to make a
playlist at some point today for it
someone asks what this app will be able
to do this app will be able to track the
level of focus that you currently have
on whatever you're doing and then warn
you when your love will focus is
dropping Charbel says what are you using
for rendering react native I'm not more
exactly sure what you mean by rendering
react native but we use expo so that's I
don't know if that's exactly what you
mean but that let me know if that
answers your question
Bentsen asked if it's morning or night
it's 12:30 p.m. where I'm at right now
bloody creature says don't waste your
time self-taught programming takes too
long well it does take a while but I
don't think it's a waste of time like to
be honest with you teaching myself to
program was a huge thing like in terms
of being able to provide for my family
like if you take like the job I had
before I started to teach myself
programming in the job I have now I make
about five times as much money per year
now as I did before and that was just
from self-taught programming so it took
me a while took me a couple years I
didn't get there overnight
I had jobs in between but you know it's
it definitely is better like you know I
didn't have to spend any money on going
to university or all that time I was
able to make money the whole time so I
don't think self-taught programming it
takes too long or is a waste of time
it's actually a really good way for me
to keep working and keep learning and
keep paying the bills and providing for
my family without having to go into debt
from student loans and stuff and now
like I'm very lucky I'm able to make
more money you know for my family than I
ever thought I would be able to so yeah
it worked out for me
a lot of people are asking like what
we're doing for this app so I explained
that a couple times already so I guess
if you're just joining and you didn't
hear the explanations you can always
rewind it like before before hand in the
stream to hear the explanation and then
come back to the like what we're doing
now if you're joining it a little bit
late and want to catch up you can always
like rewind the stream to the beginning
and then play it on double speed and
then you'll you'll get everything that
happened and you'll catch up with us on
the live so I recommend on that if you
join like in the middle and you're
totally lost that's a good option
blazing up so it's never even heard of
react native before is it good I I think
it's good I think if you already know
JavaScript then it's a really really
good way to build native apps without
having to learn different languages for
Android and iOS oh no my timer quit
again alright that's it I'm done with
this timer this is like three streams in
a row now that my timer quit working so
I got to find a new timer that one is
just not working for us I thought it had
been a long time here
alright so I didn't get through all the
questions I'm gonna stop and get back to
the code now I'll come back to the
questions though alright so we've saved
this as our app icon now we need to do a
[Music]
we need to do a splash screen which I
also have up here actually well let's
let's upload this while we're waiting so
I found this this site which is an app
icon generator which you upload your
icon in 1024 by 1024 pixels and then
it'll give you icons in different sizes
and files so let's let's do that we're
going to name it
so let's upload our file which we named
[Music]
do we name it it should be right here
unless it went to a different folder now
the default folder to save those files
is right here that's really odd let's
look in our our folder system then
that's weird let me export it again see
where it went
s F dot PNG o but went in the documents
that's weird for some reason the default
folder was documents
all right so we'll go to the documents
SF area and I want to name it the same
thing that we have in our app currently
just to like save time so it's icon PNG
mr. generate these I'm not gonna worry
about the iOS stuff for now we'll do
probably like a different stream at some
point and do the iOS build and
everything alright so we have our icons
and I want to unzip these oops I think I
open this twice yeah I did all right so
what did it send me Wow
send a lot of different files here let's
let's see what the heck it said I just
want
that's good all right well let's just
extract them all for now so we can take
a look at on me see what we want bring
this over app icons alright so this one
looks like Play Store that's what we
really want so I'm just gonna grab that
one I think yeah for now I'm just
grabbing this one I think we just need
one for now
I actually think what is the difference
with this
yeah maybe we didn't need to do that
no I'm not gonna use those
I thought we'd we'd get like different
ones that would have been that would
have worked but I think I'm just going
to pull over the file that we made so in
our documents and so we have this SF and
I'm gonna pull that over to our assets
and I'm gonna delete this icon and I'm
gonna rename this one there we go
so now that'll be our icon and we can
move on to our splash screen let's see
this is the icon page let's get rid of
this page you don't need that anymore
splash screen okay add a splash screen I
thought I had this open already I guess
not
all right 12:42 by 2436 all right now
this is for the iOS but I read through
this a little bit earlier I just kind of
skimmed through it and I believe this
will also work for Android so we're
gonna we're gonna try to do that as well
so let's go back to our image editor
okay yep
and let me I'm gonna pull this over we
don't need the full screen I'm gonna
shrink it up a little bit so we can see
our instructions as well 12:24 okay so
let's take our background and let's see
if we can resize it
no I don't think I can from there that's
so good we can do it here image canvas
size
yeah all right cool let's change the
canvas size to want with to be twelve
forty two pixels and we're going to be
24 36 pixels tall let's resize that and
let's let's put the SF part right in the
middle that looks okay
alright alright cool so now we have a
different size we have our background
here let's see if we can fill in our
background with with this color I don't
know if we can yeah it's not gonna let
us what do we need to do here let's
scale there change size resize layer to
the size of image see if that'll work
sweet that works alright cool all right
awesome
so we resize our background layer now
let's export this and let's just export
this I guess we could say we'll go SF
splash I'm saying SF because I've
decided to name the app stay focused
I don't really know first another app
name etho or how that works but that's
just the name that I thought of yep
export all right now let's move this
over
it's hilarious
let's delete our splash and change this
to splash cool
all right so we should have what we need
and I think our FJ Sun already is
showing what we need so yeah so our
splash it's already there background
color actually so let's change our
background color to match what we made
the background color for app you should
be able to find that out I think from
this this is the current there we go
there's a hex color cool
let's save that that might be the only
code change that we need to do all right
cool
and I think we're just gonna leave
everything else for the splash screens
as like the defaults and we be done with
that step and that's actually we're done
with this as well let's get rid of that
deploy
all right yeah a lot of this stuff
I'm not gonna worry about for now
okay we need Android permissions we
might need permissions for that vibrate
feature
yeah let's let's check out our
permissions here
okay so we do have vibrate alright let's
add that then
oops forget the comma Android and then
permissions and permissions is an array
of strings vibrates okay all right so we
should be good there let's get rid of
that and comment at projections I'm
gonna worry about the a projections
until we we get rejected so let's get
rid of that all right let's talk about
okay so way back to where we started
here we're still on step one installed
it install G expose okay so I am using
yarn let's just go ahead and be a
hundred percent sure that we have
installed this and we're gonna do a
global install it's just gonna work
without let's see if it works without me
running this as an admin it might give
us an error if I'm not an admin if it
does no big deal we'll just reopen as an
admin
all right we've already I believe
configured opto JSON well let's see for
Android at least looks like we're gonna
need to have a package name and a
version code I don't think we have that
yet
so let's try that let's create a package
and I guess I'll just use the your
company your app name I don't know what
my company name is gonna be just name it
after myself and your app name stay
focused and then version version code is
gonna be one version one there we go
save that still fetching packages we'll
give that another minute if nothing
happens then maybe I'll stop it and then
do it all cool just being too impatient
there looks like it's still doing its
thing see I'll do I'm gonna stop maybe
in like 10 minutes and get back to some
questions so hang in there if you if
you're asking some questions I will get
to the chat again and like I said uh so
about 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time I'm gonna
stop and do questions I went over a
little bit on the last question so
sweets
alright so we're definitely installed
now it looks like maybe I didn't have
this installed globally I think maybe I
just had it installed locally like on
this package so good thing we went
through that so that should work
named icon inversion that required Slug
is the URL name that you asked
JavaScript just pop just published to
see if we have slug I stay focused just
double checking to make sure we have
what we need
it looks good I'm not worried about iOS
for right now SDK version do we have a
yeah we do okay
let's take out iOS from our platforms
for right now since we're not targeting
iOS at the moment we'll just do android
and web we can start the Android build
okay all right this is interesting let's
let's take the time to think to
understand this here because we are
building for Android so we can do a
build apk or an Android app bundle app
bundles are recommended but you have to
make sure the Google Play apps signing
is enabled for your project you can read
more about it here okay and it looks
like we'll need a key store that they
will generate for us which is sweet cuz
I don't know what that is if you let
Expo generate a key store for you we
strongly recommend that you later fetch
the key store and backup your key store
all right we'll do that and we'll save
it in LastPass
we'll need that to update the app
all right cool let's just get wait for
it to finish building
okay
so we can call a webhook that'll let us
know when the build is done I'm not
gonna worry about that then we can test
it we'll definitely want to test it and
then we'll submit it okay so here's what
we're gonna do first we're going to test
we're gonna test it before we go through
the build because the build seems like
it may take a little bit but then test
and then we'll run this and so let's
let's do the test and this is going to
be actually let's do let's commit the
changes we made we need to get add get
commit at this message and add icons
date after JSON we're gonna push that to
get home so that's push and now let's
run yarn start
and let's try to run this on the Android
emulator
it looks like I'll have to start it
first let's do and enjoy studio this
would be a nice test of the power of
this computer to see if we can run all
this a hum you need to do a video and I
already set up a test pixel device so
let's start that up hey it was already
running the previous version before we
did it only here all the updates here
alright so now that that's running we
should be able to run this again I'm
just pressing the a button as a shortcut
to start this up I could come over here
and press the emulator button alright so
now we should get a connection here at
some point it's possible that we might
need to refresh the app which we can do
let's do a refresh now there we go all
right so now it's gonna load the new
stuff sweet so now we have the new stuff
here we can try to link let's try to
link our device and actually log in once
and see if that just to run through make
sure we don't get any crazy errors or
anything right so I need to go on my
other screen here and grab some of my
info
so I'm gonna grab device ID and password
oh no let me paste it's not let me paste
no there's gaffi there's gotta be a
setting on here too let me paste stuff
in here there's some so is there a
keyboard option
no I
there we go well at least I found the
found the dark theme if I have to
actually type out this is gonna is gonna
take five minutes to type everything out
that's crazy
you know what actually there we go
there's the paste all right if I hold in
for a second it just hit me like oh
maybe I have to paste like I do normally
on an Android device and that's you just
hold in the the button like you're
tapping like a long tap and then you get
paste so crisis averted I just should
like not make my password 70 characters
long and then maybe I'd be alright just
listen to too many hacker podcasts and
now it's made me paranoid about making
my passwords very long but I figure like
if we're dealing with data from my own
brain I should have long passwords right
sweets all right let's see so setting a
timer for a long period of time multiple
minutes is performance correctness issue
on Android let's read this what it's
saying as it keeps the timer module
awake and timers can only be called way
app is in the foreground
okay that's fine so set timeout do we
have a set timeout in our app oops I
don't need that
all right so we don't actually have a
set timeout in our code so I'm guessing
that's in maybe one of the packages
we're using so I can't really do
anything about that so I'm gonna I'm
gonna dismiss that all right cool so
this looks good we're logged in I don't
actually have the let me turn the
headset on just so that we can verify
like with with data if if we're gonna
get like if it will work with the data
once we do that we can actually do the
build another way I could test this is I
could link I could hook up my Android
phone by a USB cable to my computer and
we could test like that
but if I did that you all wouldn't be
able to see it so that's why I'm not
testing that way we did that a couple of
streams ago and in it it did work with
the previous version of the app none of
the logic has really changed too much so
I think it's it's fine it'll still work
well I don't think we can test is the
vibration feature so I don't know if
we're gonna see anything at all when the
app is supposed to vibrate but the this
notion device is starting this is the
brain computer interface I'll put this
on in a second and we should see some
real data from this as soon as the
operating system on this has started
then we'll we'll go forward with it
while I'm waiting for that which should
only be a few more seconds I'll check
the chat
I got some questions about what am i
building
it's a brain-computer app that checks
your level of focus if you want to know
more about it you can check out previous
streams or go to like the beginning of
this stream and you should be able to
get a better explanation while I'm
waiting for the device to start - I'll
remind everybody that if you're
interested in this particular device the
the notion from nur ASSA T you can check
out my youtube channel the links in the
description I did a more in-depth review
of this device and showed off some of
the stuff that it can do so check that
out I also do some coding tutorials I
just did one on typescript like an intro
to typescript I did a video on
JavaScript documentation cool what's
online so let me put this on so if if
you at all like what I'm doing here
please check out my my channel as well
and I'm trying to do since everybody's
in quarantine I'd like to do some type
of content probably like a live stream
or a video every day I'm gonna try to
alternate between live streams on free
code camp and a video on my own channel
so hopefully it's it's helpful to some
people especially if you're quarantined
by yourself I'm hoping that maybe this
is like you know a little bit of
interaction with with other developers
you know with me and with the people in
the live stream I know it's it's
probably tough tough for a lot of people
right now so I'm not a doctor I'm how at
a mental health expert but I do know how
to code so I'm gonna do that alright
this looks like it's working so as I
suspected we're not really getting the
vibration because it's a simulator so
but since I successfully tested the
vibration before on on a real device
then I'm just going to assume that it
works so cool that works
alright I'm gonna test logging out now
oh okay you know what when we log out
and nothing happens on the screen that's
interesting I think maybe we should have
something happen on the screen otherwise
users would have to like close the app
something needs to happen let's fix that
before we before we do anything else
because I think that's that's a big deal
I'm gonna take this off just for now so
I can put my headphones back up yeah I
think that that's actually a pretty that
would be a pretty annoying thing if the
user had to you know can't like
constantly restart every time they want
they logged out so let's let's fix that
now and let's see how we can do that so
when we log out what would change so
let's see right now the the login page
is shown if we don't have a user so what
does logout do so notion logout let's
find our logout function
oh we just directly called notion dot
logout let's see what we could do
I think if if we create a function
that's a logout function and we add
notion dot logout
then we can also manually clear the user
and that should that should fix it so
let's add logout function I'm gonna do a
logout and it's gonna take no parameters
and we're gonna do a notion dot logout
and we're also going to set user back to
let me see what we have going to set it
back to null set user No
okay let's save that and like a lot of
stuff is happening here we should be
able to see permission denied for what
just dismiss all that let's do a refresh
it looks like
alright let me copy my password again
mm okay
no when we log out this time it should
go back to our other screen okay cool it
did haha
oh no but we're automatically getting
logged in
we're getting we're gonna go warning
okay let's I think warnings are okay and
it won't like crash our app some okay
with that for right now if we get any
any red colored notifications that are
errors then I'll be more worried but I
do want to see so we we had the issue of
the auto logging in happening and I want
to want to make sure that we're not
doing that anymore so we had that
happening because of I believe it was
Ocean login was it this one was
automatically logging in I think it was
let's see let's see if this will work
I'm thinking that if we take out user
and set user as things that we need to
track in here that that might solve our
our issue because this won't reset let's
see
all right cool so it didn't lock us in
let's submit this and let's log out cool
all right so now everything was still
saved which is actually pretty useful
and it's not it's not doing that so
let's try to let's manually refresh just
to verify
and the thing is it's making us log in
again as we did want to avoid that we
wanted to avoid having to log in again
so I thought we had it we did have it
set up so that if we had a device ID we
would get a new notion and we would set
notion which that's actually kind of
weird that our Auto login is not working
let's test this let's run on a web
browser - because we had it working on a
web browser can't be reached
why not
okay okay it's got to build wonder if I
can run it on web in Android at the same
time all right so this is automatically
linking
it has it
alright there is some weirdness going on
with automatically starting but at least
like it does seem to be saving so it's
it's saving the ID which I'm okay with
that if the user happens to have a
password manager they can save their
password so I'm okay with that for now
alright oops I went over time I'm gonna
go back to the chat now I apologize I
totally lost track of time I should have
I should have checked the chat like 10
minutes ago so let me go to the chat now
and take about five minutes here in the
chat Hey David Corbin syriza's hey Jesse
keep up the great work
thanks man good to see you in here I
worked with David he is like a
kubernetes expert well she co says how
do you manage to stay focused over time
uh-huh I don't know I guess when I
really need to stay focused like I'm
gonna be honest I take I think like a
supplement called G fuel that's a bunch
of B vitamins and like other vitamins
and caffeine and it does help me stay
focused so that's that's what I do when
I really need to focus other than that I
I don't know just like take breaks when
I need to yeah won't boom lol says how
many years of experience do you have I
don't know it's been a lot it's been a
long time it's been a long time maybe
seven I'm trying to think back to when I
started from the time one like I
actually started getting paid to do
coding like consistently I'm gonna say
like somewhere around seven ish years
as she says it's my first live session
on free code camp Oh congratulations
welcome thanks for watching
gam 0:02 says how many hours of coding
experience would you have approximately
oh I have no idea I'd have to do some
serious math and an estimation work on
that one I don't know I mean I guess
like so if I've been coding for about
seven years full time then I mean you
figure I wouldn't say that I would have
like 40 hours a week of coding because
so much time is spent in meetings and
things like that like let's just be like
very conservative in our estimate and
say estimate 20 hours a week coding
let's factor in vacations and sick days
let's say like 20 hours per week coding
and 50 weeks a year for seven years so
let me get my calculator out because I
don't want to make simple math mistakes
live on YouTube right let's do this 20
times 50 times seven all right we're
gonna say 7000 coding hours so I guess
that's a lot of hours right and I mean
that's definitely a really big
estimation right because there were
probably some weeks when I did less than
that in some weeks when I did more than
that but that's my best estimate of of
coding which I probably have done more
than that because 20 hours a week is not
really that much and there's been times
when I've been working full-time coding
and then also have an extra part-time
project on the side but that's that's a
decent estimate I'd say I have at least
7,000 coding hours at this point bard
says hey from France hey how's it going
I a a why or how do you pronounce a
a wire but anyways what resources did
you use to study free code camp so free
cocaine bout org has a great curriculum
which is I really like it use that I
used Udacity has free code or free
courses a lot of YouTube videos there's
a YouTube channel called learn code
Academy that I really liked there's a
YouTube channel called dev tips that I
liked to watch see code Academy had some
great free content and then of course
like documentation Stack Overflow
articles and stuff Mozilla developer
Network so those are all like my main my
main resources yeah let's see and then
actually like building projects is a
great resource that's the opinion on
types Sameach says what's your opinion
on typescript will it replace javascript
in the next five years
oh I don't think it will replace Java
scripts big yeah I mean I don't really
know the numbers I haven't looked into
it that much but I doubt that it'll
replace JavaScript
charbel says make a new timer yeah I
could make a new timer somebody that
used to watch the streams a lot his
name's hard [ __ ]
he made a timer for me but I forgot the
URL so I just need to figure out what
the URL of it is and and go to that
timer that won't always worked really
well I'm gonna that was about five
minutes of chat so I'm gonna go back now
because we need to build now so the I
guess just to say like keeping the user
logged in is not working exactly like we
had it working before but it's it's
still saving the ID so I'm okay with
that
and then I guess if the user has some
sort of password manager they could save
their their other credentials in here
and I think that would be okay
maybe we could potentially give the user
an option to stay completely logged in
all the time on a future update but I
don't want to make that to default so
I'm gonna leave it off for now
plus I just really want to get this
bundled up into the App Store like I
said we are having some error messages
come up I shouldn't say error we're
having some warnings come up which I'm
okay with for now as because I don't
think it'll crash our app I think will
be will be alright so we're not having
any crashes so I think we're good to
keep on ongoing
let's do we're gonna have to save the
changes that we just made we're gonna do
an AM flag for a commit and let's do fix
cuz this was a bug let's see take
so I'm committing this and it says it's
to take user back to login screen after
logging out we're going to push that if
you want to see the code that I'm
pushing then check out the github repo
the links in the description alright
let's go to I'm gonna shut down now our
our Expo server and close out I have a
lot of Windows here that are not
necessary right now so I don't need this
right now we did that I don't think we
need this and bundles I don't think we
need this I'll keep it I must open it
for a reason so I'm gonna keep it up for
now now we're gonna do a build so let's
run the expo build for Android and then
it looks like we're gonna have to answer
some questions for this and let it run
for a little bit and while it's running
I can answer some more questions so
we're gonna do Expo build Android and I
guess what's to make a new Expo account
because I don't think I ever made one
just crazy that I've never made one
because I've been using expo for years
but I'm almost positive I do not have an
account so let's make a new one it's
cool that I don't have one because then
we get to go over the whole process live
username I'll just say J Weibull and
password I'm gonna make a password and
over here with LastPass so I can have
last class generate secure passwords
jy go already exists interesting let's
see if I have an expo account expose
I'll see if I can login forgot password
email Jessie why would she Malcolm I
opened my email on another screen here
evidently I do have an expo account well
maybe I do maybe somebody just used the
name jy go for an account well I do have
a password so I'm gonna reset my
password here on this other screen and
I'm gonna use that new password that I
just made and save password and I'm
adding this account to LastPass so we'll
have it cool let's log into my account
sweet
I have no bills
all right cool so let's try this now and
let's pick the right answer
login with existing account J Weigel
is the password sweet let Expo handle
the process definitely build iOS bundle
I said Android set Expo debug true in
your dev environment to view the stack
trace what happened
hmm maybe I hit the wrong did I hit the
wrong thing
Oh okay once I thought it would just
automatically pick that answer one
second of work no it said false why did
it say false all right what am I doing
wrong here everybody let's make this
bigger all right so it says let's try
this again
Expo build Android just there's a new
version of Expo CLI available like we
literally just installed this globally
how did we get the older version all
right let's do this let's get the new
version first of all well let's try to
npm install it this time how about that
we used yarn before maybe maybe I had
installed it with NPM originally and for
some reason it's using that one instead
of yarn one that I mean you all saw me
oh not that long ago install this so
while that's going then we will let me
double check so start the build Expo
build Android right
okay Wow
this is taking well we'll see let me go
to the chat I'll answer some questions
and then if I get your other questions
and we're still not finished with this
then we'll we'll handle that if it
happens
[Music]
we have a question that says can can you
loop through an array of audio files
hello from France hey how's it going I'm
assuming you can loop through an array
of anything I'm not sure like how the
audio files are like the format or
anything like I don't have experience
with that but if you have an array like
I'm assuming you can loop through it
Valentino says what's a brain-computer
and JJ says what's a computer this is
the brain computer it reads your
brainwaves and then sends them wherever
you want them to go like in terms of to
an app or a website or something like
that you can learn more about this I did
a video review on my YouTube channel the
links in the description for my channels
you can check out to learn more it's
called the notion and it's built by a
company called neuro City
wieszczyk says react native was fun but
flutter was better I haven't I haven't
had a chance to use flutter yet I've
heard good things about it still using
react native so yeah can't really
comment too much on that but yeah what
do you all think about flutter I don't
want to start a battle between react
neighbors and flutter because I think
they're both good but what if any of
y'all have used it you know what do you
think Tasha says what database are you
using currently I have no database setup
for this particular app so no no
database I don't know what the the neuro
CD device is has like its own operating
system and server and they might have a
database running on here and I don't
know what it is but in terms of like
what we built for this app I don't have
anything for a database arif says why
why am I here
obviously because you wanted to watch
some code right or it was an accident in
which case welcome and feel free to ask
any questions
have them lrj says I am human
excellent so am i DL TD says you also
smart which I can catch up oh don't
worry about it we're not it's this is
the fifth stream that we've done so like
if if you if anybody can like jump right
in and understand what's going on at
this point then you have to be like very
smart and experienced at this so feel
free to ask as many questions as you can
or as you want to and you know go back
and you'll watch the previous streams
definitely recommend watching them at
double speed it'll help you to catch up
and I think the streams are easier to
watch in double speed a guy I talked
kind of slowly I take my time so double
speed is better
PAP's deuces can you suggest to me some
good channels or websites for Android
development I don't know too much about
specifically Android development
he says using Java or Kotlin yeah I
don't know for sure so I know the free
code camp YouTube channel that I'm on
right now does have some videos about
different types of development so we
probably have something about Java and
Kotlin so check that out
other than that though I don't really
know too much about resources for that
a few people join saying hello so hey
how's it going
xxxx Snooki says do you have any tips
for people learning c-sharp not really
what is this telling me what's
I'm gonna close this since we can't
connect to the server anymore there we
go
closing closing a few things it just
occurred to me that hey if I closed all
this other stuff maybe this will install
more quickly so actually it did so let's
let's try to run let's try to run this
again see if we're on the right version
now and if that makes a difference right
because if if we're using the latest
instructions it's possible that because
I was on an old version that's why I
wasn't working I don't know it's just a
thought I want to see answer so I'm
trying to go up and down to see if I can
change this like up and down but that's
not working so I guess let X go handle
the process
huh
why is it doing this alright we're gonna
we're gonna have to go in to go into
research mode here for for a minute so
let's see and one thing I don't
understand is why keeps trying to build
the iOS bundle when we're trying to just
do Android let's see what we can get all
right cool
okay looks like we need to start Expo so
let's run Expo that's kind of odd I
would have thought we didn't want it
running when we do the build but I guess
that is not the case so we want to and
actually this makes sense right if it's
trying to connect then we definitely
want it running all right cool
so let's try it again
I still I don't like that it
automatically put in false for me here
because I think I need the keystore so
while this is doing its thing I want to
look look this up and see if anybody
else is having issues with that
I bowed this up already
well I guess when this is all over we'll
try to grab our key stores see if it
exists otherwise let's to figure
something out for our key store it seems
like as long as we can we have to upload
otherwise feel free to upload your own
that's weird
well
while that's happening let's let me go
back to the chat all right the last
question was do you have any tips for
people learning c-sharp I don't really
know I guess just similar tips for
learning anything try to do a little bit
with it every day just keep on like try
to try to build real projects with it
one future says how can I improve Redux
skill example or project redux is hard
I'm a junior in front end F yeah I guess
for redux try to start out with
something very simple because Redux is
difficult so try to start out with a
simple project once you see it all
working together on a project it gets a
lot easier but you know I definitely try
to find some sort of tutorial that will
give you a very simple project you know
you can check out a book the redux
documentation and go through that it's
it Redux is going to take a while for
you to understand it's just kind of
difficult at first so don't be
discouraged if it's if it's taking a
while like it's it is complex
solo code ninja says hello brother hey
how's it going
zero says you can build iOS apps on a PC
no I don't think you can I think you
could just build Android
although Expo might let you build like
maybe Expo like builded on their servers
I'm not really sure how that'll work
with with Expo but I'm I'm worried about
building the Android stuff right now I
assumed I would have to switch to my my
Mac to do the iOS stuff
zenyk says what up can you do HTML
please I don't do much like straight
HTML on on my live streams mostly I'm
doing react native nowadays Chinmay says
how much did it cost
oh the I assume you're talking about
this brain computer interface I believe
it was like $1000 somewhere around there
this was like one of like the first test
devices I don't know what the retail
price is gonna be once they they
actually have them available like the
finished product available chin maces
flutter is amazing still growing yeah
that's what I thought too
I think flutter will be a legitimate a
competitor to react native or I don't
want to say competitor because that's
like the wrong way to look at it I think
it'll be a little more legitimate option
once the community grows right one thing
I think react native has that flutter
doesn't yet just because it's a lot
older is a much bigger ecosystem more
packages available and flutter will
flutter will get there right as long as
it keeps getting growing and more people
using it it'll get there it's just it
takes time so I think right now the
flutter ecosystem is just it's just not
quite as big and I mean that comes with
there's good and bad about that like if
you want to get in and really have an
impact on an ecosystem it's way easier
to get in on an early ecosystem like
flutter than it is on something like
react native but if you just want to get
in and build stuff the odds of you
finding ready-made a you know examples
and libraries to do what you want to do
on a younger project or lower than on an
older project so it just it really
depends on what you want to do chin mace
is waiting for web RTC on flutter goods
like that's a good example it's just
depending on what you want to do it may
not be available for a younger product
it's not to say it's a bad project it's
just it's gonna take time for people to
start developing all the things that
they need
and see
mr. now now will file I'm not sure to
pronounce your name apologies for that
says what about I'll go should I have to
learn it before something programming
you mean like algorithms no you
definitely don't need to learn that
before you start programming you can
start building stuff without that see mo
says how to learn spring boots I don't
know because I don't really know it a
lot of people that I work with use it
but I I don't know very much about it at
all if anybody else knows more about it
please let us know in the chat mag
mallow says brah I just learned drop
down menus on HTML this is definitely
out of my range
oh well feel free to ask questions and
watch if you want to I understand if
it's if it's a little out of your range
but Congrats on learning drop down menus
and that's that's definitely a good
skill to have when building websites but
yeah I I really hope that these streams
would be good for people at any skill
level because I I do my best to explain
what's happening and I do take any
questions so I guess you know don't
don't try not to feel intimidated if
you're just starting out and I'm happy
to explain what's going on
vivek says will you do any machine
learning projects on the live stream I
might I might would you see you know how
this goes I think the data from the
brain computer interface you could do
some really cool machine learning stuff
with that so I'm thinking like that's a
possibility at some point and there's
some other things that I think could be
cool with machine learning that I'd like
to do so I don't have any plans to do it
in the immediate future but you know it
is on my mind for some some projects
that I've thought of Brian says love
from Kenya I love coding Oh awesome
thank you
Adrian says what react Redux package is
the best easy-peasy I'm not sure what
you mean by react Redux package if I s
if I were to start out I would use
create react app to to get started
I believe there's now a react Redux
starter with create react app where
it'll it'll scaffold without a react app
with Redux already kind of connected I
haven't used it yet I just read about it
so if I remember correctly I think that
that is out there now that would
probably be the best way to get started
with react and redux
okay I can monitor the progress of the
build at the URL which I think I already
have that open though right
sweets bill details building creating
key store key store created successfully
key source outsourced oh cool so
evidently we did get the key store
created somehow although it was not
obvious from here so let's let's check
out some of the info we're getting from
this so we're not really getting great
info in the console which is cool they
got this this thing here so let's see so
we got the key store starting the build
process icon setup native modules whoa
well build is finished
sweets nice build successful so cool
alright let's download it
get the apk very nice and it's uploaded
now to s3 very cool all right so let's
let's go to the next step here alright
so we built it's finished building let's
test it to run it on your android device
make sure you have Android platform
tools install along with ADB and then
just run ADB install with your you
plugging all right I'm gonna plug my
device in and then I'm gonna try to
install this that we've just made on my
Android device
so I forgot to bring I was gonna switch
this up and have a USBC cable I forgot
to bring it
other cable that you just need on one
end and USB seen on the other end
something
hopefully y'all heard what I was saying
I was in front of the mic okay plugging
that in
and I do have a robe on it's cold in my
basements it's not it's not that
professional but this is how I i like
the streams to be authentic and this is
how i often code it is authentic alright
so i have that plugged in now i need to
run a peb install suite so let me move
let me get rid of that let's turn that
off and I'm just gonna go out
downloads and let's see what we called
it stay focused with all kinds of stuff
so let's see ADB install and then the
file name so let's just do that
I'm pretty sure I had a DB working a DB
huh
I thought I ran an ad become in not that
long ago all right let's see how do I
get a db2 installed Android platform
tools let me open up my Android studio
tools
all right let me let me do a little
search here what was it called Android
platform tools
she get the latest SDK platform tools
for interest us SDK manager
all right so Android studio has an SDK
manager
and from the SDK manager we can get the
tools
see how this goes
I should have gotten these when I
downloaded downloaded this
let me see if anybody Oh Barrett says
maybe you installed ADB for Windows
system but not for a boon - yeah that's
possible let's see
Oh SEK tools
Android SDK command-line tools that said
not installed so it's let's shut it down
like this
cool that's kind of odd I would have
think something like that like should
have been the default but I guess not
all right cool
that was fast all right now let's see I
might have to restart the terminal yeah
or just start a new one let's see if I
got a dB
try I doubt it would work in my Linux
sub system yeah
oops those accident maybe I'll just try
to do it this way see if it works
I thought I just did this
you
it already exists why didn't it write in
an update that's sweet
oh there we go now how do I install that
samosas add a DV in variable environment
[Music]
I wonder if I actually have access to
any of the Android tools that's very
weird
nothing manases add to environment path
yes see I add a DB let's see
all right cool let's try this open
Windows Explorer right-click my PC
properties that system settings the
varmint variables we got path double
click it okay browse oops
c program files adb
Phoebe
I'm not seeing where to add this
oh I'm Anderson just copy the downloaded
folder path and that is a new path oh
that's right we did download that
okay
alright that'll add it to Windows Pass
okay totally didn't see this first
section that seems like the easier one
but it looks like we don't have the dot
exe so you just have the DLLs unless um
Oh actually fast-food a DV application
yeah you could copy that to see Windows
and they should be good to go from the
command line
I see let's do that let's just copy I'm
gonna copy those and then
all right so either way that should work
at least for the windows part which is
fine because I'll do a command from and
let's see if we can do it now a DB yes
it works all right cool so we got a lot
of stuff going on here okay oh goodness
okay so back to where we need to go for
there we go now I forget it actually let
me look here cool I'm a DB here as well
which is sweet so I'm already in the
downloads here so let's just rerun this
command that we just ran cool so this
should perform an install on my phone
success all right so how do I actually
run this then
alright let's verify ok so I have a
device
who
it says it's installed but I don't I
didn't see anything happen on my phone
interesting okay those troubleshoot that
then
okay let's see manna says it's much
easier to have a copy of the apk on your
phone and then install it manually I
could probably do it through Google
Drive right okay upload the apk
I'll do that on my other screen I'm just
uploading the apk
oh there we go works
it's in the process of uploading and I
guess I'll start it on my device in all
right cool so it uploaded just go to
Google Drive I mean I would like to know
why it's not working but you know just
to get this started we can do the upload
here let's see where's my Google Drive
download this downloading it to my
device now
cool download works it's installing
so we'll say as I'm installing this
twice it opened to give me like security
warnings because this is three times its
it's had their security warnings here
but it's opening so if you can see that
it is open on my machine so that's
that's pretty cool let's I guess I can
I'm going to try to run this on my
device so I'm gonna copy and paste my my
key about like my device ID into Google
keep so that I can easily copy and paste
it into my phone and try it on my phone
let's see cool Google keep sinks very
quickly it's really good for this kind
of stuff I'd pasted that in let's put my
email in and a password I'll go into my
LastPass and say nope I need the Raza T
alright hopefully it's just the right
password nice
all right cool so it's working so
obviously I'm getting it's vibrating I
know if you can hear that you can hear
that on the mic now it's vibrating and I
don't have headset on so obviously like
I'm not focused right and it's giving me
this red this red message sweet I'm a
log out now so it stops with all this
vibrating oh no I logged out and it's
still vibrating and red that's a bug but
at least the vibrating only goes on for
maybe like 10 seconds at the most maybe
less than that
but all right that's cool all right very
cool so it works and I believe I have
like stay focused icon now in my phone
which is really sweet so I could find it
yeah so the little SF isn't an icon very
cool
all right so that works I'm going to go
through the next step now of let's get
rid of this and submit it
uploading apps
so to upload the previously built
standalone app to app store you
something around Expo upload Android but
I thought we have to do we have to
create an account download this JSON
private key after that you have to
create an app on Google Play console and
upload you got manually at least once
all right so we got a go to Google Play
console which cool now I already signed
up for an account on here so you would
have to do that step let's create an app
we're gonna call it stay focused
short description alert you when you
start to lose focus and the full
description is works with the porosity
current level of focus the lace vibrates
alright cool graphic assets
screen shots we gotta add at least one
phone screenshot
alright well I guess I'll take a screen
shot from my phone then in download
alright alright I guess I'll upload the
screenshot to my Google Drive so that I
can get it back down there
I know it's been a while since I've
gotten to the chat so I'll get back to
the chat in just a minute
let's try to get this screenshot
uploaded all right so the screenshots
being uploaded to Google Drive I got my
drive open on my other windows so I
should be able to see when it gets there
yep it's there now I'm gonna download
that screenshot and should be able to
there we go uh-oh need to resize your
screenshot okay it's too big feature
graphic goodness I need all this stuff
it's application productivity content
rating
man there's a lot of stuff to do this
alright well let's just keep going then
all right high res icon let's see if we
can use that icon that we created
dimensions required or 512 by 512 okay
so let's take all right so if I'm just
resizing stuff I like to use Pickler I
can't figure out how to get it log on
actually editor which one is the I
remember this is different than what I
was looking for maybe II open image
image size there we go
I hopefully that'll work
so this is probably boring I didn't
realize how much was involved and now
this one needs to be minimum length 320
interesting all right at least two
screenshots are required oh we need at
least two huh well I guess I'll take
another one then let me do one logged
out I guess there we go
okay so let's go into the editor then
and let's get a new image and upload
this image so we got this screenshot you
know we want a new size and it needs to
be what was it three
minimum length for any side 320 max
length for any side three eight four
zero so what do we have
that seems like it fit though didn't it
let's try that again because it's
between 320 pixels and 3840 pixels let's
try that show that again see what it
says you do resize your screenshot
max
aspect ratio 2 to 1 maybe when maybe
we're not hitting the aspect ratio see
image size
let's see let's see see if we got
something that'll do it for us app
screenshot builder I don't want to
create an account
No
all right let's see Harish says used
bulk resize photos comm okay I'll try
that
make sure what about this one
cool
see this is cool no what can I do with
this
if this work that's gonna be gonna be
sweet
let's open this and extract to download
screenshots okay screenshots all right
let's try where we add
check it a work nice screenshot to uh
sweets nice feature graphic what the
heck is a feature graphic 1024 by 500
okay let's go back to this so much more
image editing than I am ever used to
doing this is crazy
Oh where you go let's take our let's
take this and use the what 1024 by 500
should see if we can just take this and
do I guess we'll have to do the whole
canvas canvas size
it was just 1024 by 500 okay interesting
all right let's take this text then and
there we go that's export as know they
want this as PG SF
well this is called feature bear with
everybody it's the first time I've ever
done this I guess this went to documents
yes alright what else do we need
I don't have a promo video put that in
tags alright
tags no I don't the save draft now I
would hate to actually lose anything to
be done here alright so so far I think
we've got everything that we need up to
here I guess we don't need tags content
rating we're gonna do here you must
upload an apk before taking the content
rating questionnaire okay
that looks good that's good so we'll
skip that for now website I don't have a
website please provide an email address
there we go phone number hey now y'all
know my phone number
privacy policy if you wish for a privacy
policy please senator below I don't have
one right now hopefully that won't be an
issue now where can I go
where can I applaud this apk did I miss
it
let's do a beta release I'm guessing a
beta release would have less
restrictions
I don't know let me see production
all right let me go back I'm gonna go
back to the chat before I do anything
else just to see if anybody has anything
like to say about this particular
process right here see
Ohio says you could use a policy
generator and add the Google Doc link oh
that's a great idea let's do that
they'll have a company name no gotta
provide my address for my company is
registered I don't have it
oh my goodness so many questions what
fine
what can I do with this so I say all
right let's just put this in a Google
Doc
[Music]
awesome that was a good idea let's let's
go to the store listing and I will add
in a privacy policy save that as a draft
okay
excellent now I need to I need to figure
out I guess I got to go to the app
releases two issues for internal testing
within minutes
I mean how
I just wonder which one would be the
best to do so did the GU good luck let
me see let me go back to Expo and see
ppi-yak says create a service account
new project
all right
let's do the API access and create a
service account
I'm not sure if I was allowed to have
this looks like the public key so I
guess it's fine if that's in the
building an app what do you think pretty
cool how are you doing today good good
she had everybody
see boots
nobody needs daddy would on to use one
of those that's a brain-computer you
wear it read your brain what do you
think so you want to see it on the
screen
let's say rain was cool suicidal oh this
is a Cordelia my daughter is wearing the
headset and this is these are her brain
waves well they were until I move the
screen let's start it again did
something happen hmm see if just signal
quality's okay
it's probably too big let me shorten it
up for you baby here we go I put your
head down there we go okay see if we get
some better signals here your hair's a
lot longer than mine too
might be a problem hope it's almost out
of batteries I left it on this whole
time there you go we got some brain
waves oh we got a little bit got a
little bit going on I don't know what
the problem is I refresh
here we go as crazy anyways look pretty
crazy huh what your brain doing taking
it from my daddy oh yeah I put this one
crooked too I think there we go it's
probably gonna run out of batteries but
that's kind of cool yeah I'll put this
on the other screen you can see you can
keep looking at it how about that I'm
gonna keep looking at your brain we're
just doing making all those colors okay
so anyway I followed a couple of links
and got to this in terms of like the
first thing so I guess there's two
things to do one is create this account
and then that way we don't have to keep
manually uploading we can just use the
expo command line to do it then we can
then we can do the manual upload for the
first time so let's do these steps and
you know it's going to be crazy so after
all of this we're still not gonna have
the app ready until they actually do the
review so it'll take a while before we
get it actually in the in the app store
I want to close out all these that we're
not using now
okay all right let's see settings API
access create service account
let's just let's split the screen here
so we can follow the instructions you're
done okay good job good job baby okay
all right so let's go with parser
settings
going up here No
we make this bigger
Google Play console I believe this is hi
this is Google Play console yes there we
go there settings okay
API access
create service accounts daddy why do you
think why do you fill up your water and
then bring your water down here
hmm daddy daddy - still getting yeah cuz
we have a civil one okay alright so for
the Google API console link in the
dialog there was no dialogue just work
telling ever an elbow a deck create
service account okay to create service
account I turned it off hits a button
this little button
yeah there you go see it'll turn off now
you know show on the screen
see it's just shutting off you see right
there shutting off senile order line sir
oh they will stop okay
and your name daddy thank you okay just
taking a long time yeah now here great
service account see play oh it's not old
I just got it a couple months ago all
right hey no hidden buttons
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey hey don't you go upstairs and
play no you wanna play down here you can
hit that keyboard won't you okay
all right so we wanted to be able to
release manage click on grant access and
release manager so role was release
manager I guess I'm just gonna keep the
defaults and add a user all right cool
now we can manually upload so let's go
to manual upload instructions so many
instructions I definitely need to do
this again like very quickly with like
making another app because otherwise I
will forget so much of this I do have
some other apps that I never quite got
finished maybe I'll try to finish them
and do it you know what cuz I turned off
the power strip because the fishtank was
being really noisy why don't you go
upstairs and play on the Chromebook you
wanna see if you can play on the
Chromebook you want to go tell the other
kids that I'm I build an app for the
phone no oops you want to play something
go see if Raphael will let you play the
switch
you see if you'll turn it on for you and
play Mario
tell him I told you to let's see get
your app ready for testing if you touch
all right so we did the create
application take the content rating
questionnaire and set up so I believe we
created the store listing where so we
did all that next steps take the content
rating questionnaire so how do we do it
all right sign it in place select an app
all right let's go to our Play console
we'll move it over here select an app
stay focused okay
now on the left menu click store
presents content content rating you must
upload before taking all right well I
guess we got to upload
that's it's very odd
I mean as a PK for
all right well yes let's do the releases
then and production track you have at
least it hasn't been rolled out no one
is
which wonder is this the key that we
created
Dimitri says you need to do everything
that's marked with a great checkbox
step require if you're using they
recommended a publishing format the
Android app bundle yeah I mean I think
I'll go with that one then okay on the
left hand side oh thank you Demetri so
to me shows everything that has this
little gray checkbox needs to be done
before we can distribute that thank you
that's very helpful all right so let's
accept that cool let's browse file and
get this apk
see it is
I wonder if isn't gonna work because we
have a different key we're not using
that key we'll see
release notes this is initial release
if you wanted message
all right so we could use the Android
app bundle all right let's see which I
thought we were we did read about that
and thought we're gonna try to do that
all right let's let's try this then
maybe we didn't build the right one we
need to start forget
alright cool let that run for a minute
while we take care of some of the other
stuff we need to there we go alright so
let's get back to see if we could do
this
yep cool okay up category
cool
cool looks like a good rating nice
I just get that one done have content
let me start okay it's free
no ads
integrate my services with app actions I
don't really know what that is do not
prove
all right
okay
all right cool eventually I do want to
use this with Android auto but it's not
ready for that yet
all right cool that says to go back to
this cool target audience I guess it's
not one of your target age group 18 and
older I mean let's just do 18 and older
about that there we go all right cool
then we get the release and Expo
whoa
all right cool so looks like we got
everything we need right now this accept
this build this newer build where is it
what part is it at running Gradle
alright so got through a bunch of steps
so basically we got a warning on our on
our release saying that we could have
done it basically better if we used a
different a different apk so I thought
like a maybe we just do this but it's
still building so I guess if the bill
doesn't succeed very soon I'm just gonna
do this just to kind of try it out for
our first try and I can always shut
upload the other build later on yeah
so I think that's probably Dmitri says
going straight to production not the
best idea yeah I wasn't really sure what
the if I should try production first or
not like the app is just very basic and
it's not gonna be a big audience because
you need the neuro City device to use it
I thought about doing a beta what do
y'all think let's let's decide here so
who thinks we should go straight to
production or should we go to beta or
even alpha so basically options are
should we go - should we do beta
okay so beta track is public I kind of
do want it to be public for everybody
that has a necessity notion device to
try it so the options are either beta or
production at this point so let me know
what you think
and I'll check this this is still still
working
oh okay we've got some it's actually
pretty close in terms of votes here
between beta and production it looks
like 1/4 I'm assuming Dimitri is leaning
towards beta since he's the one that
said production isn't a good idea so
beta has one two three four votes
production production only has two so
let's give it just another like few
seconds we have a vote for gamma okay
thinking about harvest says for this
kind of app I would pick production
nothing to risk at all I mean yeah
that's I mean I kind of thought like
listen risk how about okay productions
get making a comeback now I think we're
about about even I just wonder what let
me I want to see what the difference
would be because it seems to me that if
everybody if it's still like available
then I guess beta would be fine because
I would like let the users know like hey
this is the very first like Oh Demetri
says one difference between production
and beta is an app store there's a text
beta in the title yeah I could see like
it's true I don't want people to think
this is a completely finished app so
maybe beta is the right way to go
because there are definitely more
features I want to add we didn't really
try to make it look amazing yeah I think
I think we can try beta so we'd ever
want to do open beta maximum number of
testers if you set the maximum it needs
to be at least a thousand it's I don't
really care how many people use this I
don't know how many I'll just put that
in feedback I guess
and it's edit release all right so
that's enabled that's
I guess one all right initial release
one and then so that's still not a
finished I cool let's try this one then
yeah so we're gonna try to upload the
new one we'll see if this if this goes
well now technically we didn't test this
one so this is definitely the beta uh
yeah this is it and this is an a a B not
an apk so it's the I guess the newer
version that's recommended so it's
uploading pretty quickly should be ready
soon it looks like we completed all the
other steps so this might be the last
step and this has been quite a long
stream how long we've been going for I
don't even know what's the time
three hours yeah sounds about right we
started a new yeah a three hour stream
crazy I'm like super hungry and actually
I was supposed to there's a like a
online meet up for this neuro City
notion device that I can't remember if
it started at 2:00 or 3:00 either way I
think I'm late for it at this point all
right it starts at 3:00 so I'll be I'll
be fashionably late processing uh-oh you
need to use a different version code for
your apk or do it because you already
have a version we'll just we'll code one
oops
I don't know wait a second
there's a version code is that gonna
does that mean if that means I have to
rebuild it then I'm definitely not doing
that where's the code app JSON I'm
afraid yeah version I I think we had to
bump the version so I'm just gonna go
back to the old the other one or I could
remove it I say at this point I just
used the one that we already uploaded
that worked with the apk version code
one and then because I don't want to go
through rebuilding again that's look
like seven minutes to build that's I
don't wait another seven minutes all
right we'll try that one
there we go
review
which we know that that was the case so
oh cool I can for rollout seconds ago
okay Dimitri says it's practically
impossible to change the key with which
you sign your app so be careful not to
leak or lose it
good good tip thank you for that so do I
need to create the release now or what
set the next step we did that next step
publisher
I guess we do a release not now we just
did one
so did it did it actually release yeah
I'm assuming that like release means
it's it still needs to be reviewed and
it's not actually available no
production releases I understand that
okay so we have beta cool so it's
pending so they're reviewing the app so
basically at this point I think
everything we can do has been done the
app review has to happen before it gets
it gets launched so this could take a
while so I think there's other stuff
that I want to do for the app I don't
know if we'll hold off on that until we
get here back for the release or we'll
just keep working on it oh I'll figure
it out but yeah at this point I'd say
we're gonna just gonna finish up the
stream so yeah thank you so much for
watching I'm gonna look I've been
keeping up with the chat pretty well so
I don't know that there's there's too
much left in here that I haven't
addressed and just just double checking
now also a few you're saying that when
my daughter was down there saying she's
adorable cute child thank you I
appreciate it
all right cool so
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna finish up and thank you
all so much for watching how much I do
another stream in two days so what's
this Saturday so probably like Monday
afternoon Eastern Time will probably be
my next stream and I'm not sure what
we'll what we'll do in this stream we'll
work on it and yeah I'll post it in in
Twitter
so before I stream I always post in
Twitter and LinkedIn and on Instagram
that I'm going to stream I believe it
also automatically posts to Facebook as
well and then if you turn on
notifications for free code camp then
you'll get notifications as well I do
put out videos on my channel so if you
would like to get notified about those
as well
you can check the link in the
description and sign up for
notifications from my channel too those
are the best ways to find out when I'm
when I'm gonna be streaming or when I'm
gonna release new videos I'm gonna have
a new video coming out on my channel
tomorrow I still have to create that
video and I'm not 100% sure what it's
gonna be about how but I have a list of
topics and I'm gonna pick one and make a
video tonight and release it tomorrow
I'm gonna try for tomorrow morning as a
release eastern time so I will hopefully
be back then in the meantime have a
great West rest of your weekend and be
safe Thanks